I have been an absolute wreck for about
since Ahmad Arbor II that's the first
one that just punched me in my de
because you could see him in that video
scared for his life and then seeing
Brianna Taylor and having a sister
that's a nurse trying to better herself
and then to see this woman I saw all
myself and her and that took me down
even a darker space and that I've been
crying for weeks and then to see George
Floyd I was like and I had posted black
like me after a mod if you go through my
Twitter I posted black like me in my
Twitter feed for a mod I was like this
is for you
[Music]
painted picket fence
I didn't get permission I didn't tell
anybody I was just like I couldn't
believe I had a song that expressed
everything that we feel and and so I
posted it just a few days ago and the
response was just like
[Music]
you should try to be
it was my pain you know I was writing
about my pain and to know that it can
help other people and it's it's just
such a beautiful God moment